[Music]
they are Earth's Mightiest Heroes but
how much do you really know about the
Avengers here are 10 Avengers facts you
may not know what's in a name when you
think of the Avengers you probably think
of heroes like Iron Man Thor Black Widow
and Captain America but it was another
superhero who actually gave the team its
name a character that still hasn't even
appeared in the movies except in one
little flashback that's right Janet Van
Dyne the wasp was a founding member of
the Avengers in the comics and even came
up with the name to the Nick Fury's
always trying to take credit for
everything I'm here to talk to you about
the Avenger initiative
wasps for widows while she may be
missing from the team she named there
was a point in time where the wasp would
have made a cinematic debut in the
original Avengers movie writer director
Joss Whedon explained in a Q&A session
after a screening of the movie that had
written the wasp into the early drafts
of the screenplay there was a little bit
of time that we thought we might not
actually get scholar
there was a very waspy draft that I
wrote but it was way too waspy I was
like she's adorable I'm just gonna watch
her eventually Johansson did sign up
bringing the Black Widow back to the
screen and the wasp got squashed good
hey wasps Hulk smash membership Kurt in
the movies The Hulk is one of the most
high-profile members of the team however
he was only an Avenger for a single
issue in the comics he formed in the
last panel of Avengers number one and by
the end of the second issue he'd already
quit in a rage what a baby a few issues
later I recently in frozen Captain
America replaced the Hulk and the rest a
superhero history Kang outfoxed as the
second movie in the franchise shows
Ultron is one of the most important
Avengers villains but another nemesis
stands out as our all-time biggest
threat Kang the Conqueror a
time-traveling warlord who has menaced
the team since 1964 so why hasn't he
appeared in an MCU film yet because even
though he made his debut as an Avengers
bad guy he's also closely associated
with the Fantastic Four and according to
guardians of the galaxy's director James
Gunn Marvel included the film rights to
Kangas part of their Fantastic Four
contract with 20th Century Fox
as a result Kang is probably off the MCU
table for good
Avengers disassembled one of the most
infamous moments in Avengers history
took place in issue 16 in which the
entire original team quit only to be
replaced by reformed supervillains why
such a drastic roster change
well because Iron Man Thor giant man and
the wasp
were starring in their own solo comics
and Marvel mastermind Stan Lee was
getting confused about the continuity
did it work
rather than spend time figuring out each
month when each Avenger happened in
relation to the others he decided to
just feature different characters who
weren't appearing in other comics
Avengers age of Makena if you've ever
looked at old Tron and thought it was
pretty well suited to be an evil robot
you can thank a comic book called
Captain video specifically issue number
three from 1951 according to an
interview of Ultron's co-creator Roy
Thomas artist John Buscemi was partially
inspired by the villain Makino's creepy
design just take a look at that perma
smile on his face visions of other
worlds
speaking of writer Roy Thomas did ask
Stanley if he could add a member to the
Avengers in 1968 he reportedly wanted to
resurrect the long-forgotten Golden Age
superhero character who first appeared
in Marvel Comics number 13 back in 1940
an alien known as the vision an alien
cop from a smoke dimension who comes to
earth the battle mystical crime but Stan
Lee had other plans
asking that a new addition to be a robot
of some kind so Thomas imbue sima simply
took the name and design provision and
used it to make a new robotic version
and this one could even cry comic book
casting follow along with this one if
you can wander but in the comics Nick
Fury was originally a white world war
two vet who eventually became an agent
of shield when Marvel updated the
character in the early 2000s for their
Ultimate Universe artist Brian hitch
decided to use samuel l.jackson as a
model for the new version of Nick Fury
so when Marvel Studios produced the
first Iron Man movie back in 2008 and
the post-credits scene called for a
cameo from Fury there was only one man
for the job
samuel l.jackson who the hell are you
Nick Fury director of shield once the
movies became a hit Marvel decided to
make the comic book Nick Fury in the
main Marvel Universe much the film's to
explain the change the original Theory
got a previously unknown Afra
Americans son appropriately named Nick
Fury jr. who took over running shield
for dear old dad these days Nick senior
is out of the picture because he's been
chained to the moon other we're gonna
have we robe was an Avengers villain
back in 1980 ones Avengers annual number
ten the heroes face off against a
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants which
boasted a new member a superpower
stealing villain named rogue two years
later she switched sides and joined the
x-men since then she's become one of the
most famous members of the mutant super
team though that's partly because of her
southern charm you're as fast as a swamp
bug on a hot skillet just Whedon
superhero scribe on the subject of
marvelous mutants Avengers writer
director Joss Whedon actually had the
opportunity to take a crack at the
mutants first big-screen adventure he
told the a/v Club that had been invited
to punch up the script for the first
x-men movie so what happened
Whedon explained not only did they throw
out my script and never tell me about it
they actually invited me to the
read-through having thrown out my entire
draft without telling me apparently
however one line he wrote did make it
into the final film hey it's me prove it
you're a dick meanwhile a few years
later Warner Brothers invited Whedon to
write and direct a Wonder Woman feature
film but the project was scrapped in
2007 incredibly Whedon's Avengers movie
in 2012 earned 1.5 billion and made the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the envy of
Hollywood for Avengers fans there's only
one thing to say to 20th Century Fox and
Warner Brothers for their mistakes dude
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment let us know which Avengers facts
surprised you the most
[Music]